okay thanks for the invitation and the
opportunity to speak this will be
similar to some of the things you've
heard already and that the previous
speakers have have already kind of given
you the the introduction for for this
talk which is the notion that now with
the ability to sequence many cancer
genomes can we identify the mutations
that are causing cancer and
distinguishing them distinguish them
from those that are that are merely
passengers now ultimately that's a
biological distinction and one has to go
do an experiment to figure out which are
the functional mutations when which are
the random passengers but we might be
able to get information about how to
prioritize these experiments by finding
genes that are mutated more than we
expect by chance and so this has been
one of the motivations for large
projects like the Cancer Genome Atlas
and the International Cancer Genome
consortium and when we first got
involved in in one of these projects
they were at the time using a method to
prioritize which genes are mutated more
than than expected by chance and now
there are many such methods and it's not
such an easy thing to actually develop
such methods but no matter how you try
to prioritize one gene at a time you're
sort of left facing a picture like this
which is as you rank genes by their
significance you tend to get a
relatively small number of genes which
you can say are significantly mutated
with the some comfortable level of
statistical significance followed by
this long tail of rarely mutated genes
and we know that not all the important
cancer genes are in this leading edge
and that there are many important cancer
genes and mutations in in this long tail
so how can we do better and dig into
this and more importantly how what's the
explanation for this for this picture
why do we sort of imagine that there
would be such a phenomenon and of course
at this meeting it's not a surprise and
if you talk to many biologists they give
you a one-word explanation for this
picture which is the explanation we
heard on the teleconference with that
which was that this is all just pathways
this pathway so somehow magically
pathways sort of explain this picture
and of course you know to some extent
they do and we know that genes don't
work on their own they work together and
in pathways and networks and so somehow
we should be explaining this data using
using
pathways if you look at many cancer
sequencing papers and particularly those
safe from the Cancer Genome Atlas you'll
see these beautiful pictures that show
you these mutations clustering on on
pathways but when we read the first of
these papers which is actually not shown
here it's the glioblastoma paper we
thought well this is a really beautiful
picture it's a great illustration of the
data on top of the known pathways that
that we know about but you know what's
what's the p value of this picture there
is none there was none that was computed
is this the most important grouping of
mutations that that are found in the
data perhaps there's some other pathway
we should have been exploring so we sort
of do a thought experiment we think that
cancer is driven by mutations in
pathways then with enough data should we
be able to discover the pathways
shouldn't they somehow reveal themselves
we could have discovered the pathways by
one gene at a time sort of you know
figuring out that it's a cancer gene but
could we do better of course we can test
known pathways and we've heard about
about this extensively and there are
great tools for doing this but you know
that won't tell you anything new and it
won't somehow show you somehow the
picture that that's being Illustrated
here where there's you know there's
interactions there's topology these
networks it's not just a gene set so
what could we do and and of course this
is already sort of been previewed you
know rather than testing known pathways
could somehow reduce our prior knowledge
and find these combinations of course as
we do so the number of combinations that
we need to explore grows exponentially
so we can't go and test all combinations
but there must be something in between
and what could be in between well one
might be an interaction network is we've
already sort of heard and I'll continue
that theme but we might also be able to
do other things which you also have sort
of been previewed and I won't really
have that much time to discuss where we
can use signals of mutual exclusivity or
anti correlation between mutations so to
set up for the the first approach here
is we're given mutation data here it
might be single nucleotide mutations and
genes were given copy number aberrations
we've given mutation data various types
we're given some prior knowledge of
interactions this could be a
high-throughput data it could be your
literature curated interactions choose
your favorite representation of the
human interaction network and
how can you combine these things how can
you let the data lead you to the sub
networks that are mutated more than
expected by chance so we started working
on this a few years ago there were you
know various methods for finding modules
and graphs but there wasn't really a
method that address this problem
directly of course you need to account
for the topology the small world
power-law shortest you know shortest
path between nodes etc you need to also
though somehow account for the score on
the gene somehow the frequency with
which it's mutated and the topology of
the network and you'd like to do these
things simultaneously you know what a
sort of threshold your genes and then
only use that the topological properties
of the network and then there's somehow
a statistical concern here because you
need to go and pull out these
significantly mutated networks so in
order to address these challenges we
developed this method which was called a
hot net and you sort of heard heard
about this a little bit in brief there's
sort of a the idea that you think of
mutations as sources of heat on the
graph you allow that heat to diffuse for
some length of time that will sort of
smooth out the scores over the network
and then you break the network by
removing cold edges and thereby finding
these hot sub networks and there's a
statistical test that one employ so I'm
going to dig into the that the details
of this a little bit after you know
showing you some results so it's been
applied to several TCGA studies over the
years and several years ago we started
working on this pan cancer project which
was over three thousand samples an order
of magnitude more samples than we'd ever
analyzed in any lease published studies
where we gotten what we thought were
nice results and and and we thought well
this is great this is a big data set
we've got we've got great data we've got
the data we've got the tool we've got
the talent and and we're going to you
know just do this and I reportedly
perhaps even said that this will be the
easiest nature paper ever I don't recall
saying that but I'm told I perhaps I did
say this and here's what the data look
like just to sort of show you 12 cancer
types here's the number of samples
they're sort of color code in this nice
way here's the sort of long tail
phenomenon showing certain two
dimensions we're indicating the number
of samples with a mutation in it and in
a single nucleotide mutation of gene a
number
samples with a copy number aberrations
in the gene for those who they work at
cancer data you'll recognize these
well-known outliers sort of a who's who
of cancer genes p53 mix ccnd1 egfr etc
and here's this sort of long tail shown
in two dimensions and we know there's
lots of great cancer genes in here
they're just too rare to be sort of
identified on their own or many of them
are so let's run hot in on this data and
we did that and the results were not so
great and we thought maybe this is a
problem of the parameters and we tweak
the parameters and what we could not get
rid of where these artifacts of highly
mutated genes like p53 that were sort of
sending all their heat to their
neighbors and this was you know the
phenomenon that was always in the
algorithm but somehow we'd never noticed
it because when we increase the number
of samples by an order of magnitude the
dynamic range from the most mutated to
the least mutated gene also increased
and so you know now we have this problem
where the hottest genes were much hotter
than the coldest genes the other way
think about this is the rare the long
tail these rare genes there's a lot more
of them okay so this was always a
problem we hadn't noticed it somehow the
big data set didn't help us had pointed
out sort of an issue with with the
algorithm so so Fabien vandeen who you
heard from earlier it sees no other
dates right yes now professor vending
working with Max lysosome where my PhD
students decided that that we needed to
address this now when I talk to a
biology audience usually I just give the
dissolution right but I thought maybe
this was the audience that would
tolerate perhaps even appreciate some
equations although it's right before
lunch so looking around I'm not sure
that I made the right choice here yes oh
yes
yeah this is this is a cross all steps
yeah so there's three yes yeah this is
pan-cancer analysis three thousand
samples we forget about which type they
are so p53 is in a little under half the
samples will come back to all that let's
do our mathematical interlude before
it's too hot so much um okay so here we
are so what's really going on with the
algorithm so what's what's what's hot in
hot net well haughton that has to
somehow use heat heat is is given by the
heat equation and and so the heat
equation you might remember from maybe
not if you ever took differential
equations there's there's a equation
that describes how heat flows in space
you can do the same thing on a graph and
you can describe how heat flows on the
graph the equation is that the rate of
change of heat is is just proportional
to the difference in heat along adjacent
vertices so you can just write all this
down you can write down this
differential equation in terms of just
the adjacency matrix of the graph
actually it just ends up being written
down in terms of what's called the
laplacian matrix of the graph and you
could solve in the solution is given by
this matrix exponential so now i can
describe the heat at time T on any
vertex just by multiplying this matrix
which is given just by the laplacian of
the graph times the initial heat
sometimes called the the heat colonel so
what that means now is that we can sort
of propagate heaton and this is sort of
related to think algorithms you may have
heard about called network propagation
by taking some initial distribution of
scores here's these might be our gene
scores and you multiply them by this
heat kernel and you get the heat on the
vertices after this time T and then you
can somehow interpret these these scores
so this is but sometimes called network
propagation similarly you might instead
think of you know nodes that you might
indicate our perhaps cancer genes and
then mark those is with a heat of one
and other genes with the heat of zero
somehow these seed vertices and then
multiply by that vector and you get a
ranking of vertices relative to the seed
notes some of you may have seen this and
this is roughly called network
prioritization okay now a few of you
might be thinking well what am I going
to have for lunch
but some of you might be thinking then
you know I've read about network
prioritization and network propagation
but it's not heat they use a random walk
it's supposed to be a random walk that's
what we were supposed to do well in fact
it's the same thing most of the time
some of you know and in this case in
fact as he turned all over this heat
equation is exactly the same equation as
you get if you did a lazy random walk on
the graph meaning at every time step
with probability alpha I pick one of the
neighbors and with the remaining
probability I stay where I am and it
gives me the exact same equation so the
probability that I end up at various
nodes at time T is just given by this
initial distribution times this heat
kernel and this is a one example of a
beautiful connection between random
walks and diffusion processes which is
true in Euclidean space but also true on
graphs this is the continuous-time
version most computer scientists don't
do the continuous-time version because
graphs are discrete we're used to
discrete things we do discrete time
version but but the idea is the same you
get a slightly different equation like
this yeah so all this method is a notion
of conservation on peace yes giving each
each node a little bit less so mhm yes
if in France it isn't it may be a
recitation there's nobody stopping that
note to be influencing all the nodes
with the same influence you know yeah so
what this is doing is yeah I mean it's
it's essentially ends up down waiting
high degree knows to some extent is that
the right thing yeah i mean i think it's
it's a good question i just 1 i'm kind
of hope we get into in the discussion
this afternoon so this kind of printer
part of the reason I'm bringing all
these things up okay so this is it this
is the lazy random walk but in fact some
of you are thinking this is not the lazy
random walk is anyone thinking this no
one's thinking this you should be
thinking this because if you look at
most literature the lazy random walk is
actually this one where you stay at a
node with the same probability so your
laziness is equal at every node and then
you transition to other nodes
if with different probability so see the
difference we call this kind of locally
lazy random walk this one kind of the
global lazy random walk your lazy
equally with no matter where you are
they're both in the literature called
the lazy random walk so it's actually
somewhat annoying and and even more than
that the equation the matrix you get
here is slightly different okay doesn't
look too much different it's slightly
different but actually this one is is
not a symmetric matrix whereas this one
was right and amazing if you look at
some of the papers about half the time I
don't know if it's half they actually
transpose this equation and it could be
a typo we don't know but you know maybe
it's corrected in their code maybe it's
a typo in the paper and correct in the
cove makes the type on the code and
correct in the paper no one ever knows
so sort of a frustrating thing but it's
also the lazy random walk all right so
that's good but then a very very small
number of you are thinking well this is
not networked prior organization because
we don't use the random walk you're
supposed to use the random walk with
restart which is a slightly different
random walk where you transition to each
node with some probability but then with
probability 1 minus beta you just jump
or teleport to any other node in the
graph and that is given by this
preference vector where you sort of
teleport so the equation changes here
slightly you get a different matrix it's
called a page rank matrix because if you
make this vector the uniform vector then
the distribution you get is what's
called the page rank vector of the graph
which is you know multi-billion dollars
for google this is how web pages are
wrecked right it's all sort of related
really right you're changing things ever
so slightly right okay so there was our
interlude sorry interlude now let's get
back to hot net to the equations are
still here though because now I want to
sort of put this in context so the
original hot net we use the heat
equation actually the original thing
that wasn't called hot bad we didn't use
the heat equation but that's another
story but in the one that was called on
that we use the heat equation and then
here's the sort of one sort of slight
thing what we end up doing is ranking
nodes one at a time relative to all the
other notes so each column of this is
one of these network propagation or
prioritization things but you do this
once for every node okay so that you're
multiplying by this vector so the end
result is not a single distribution over
vertices but what can be interpreted as
a similarity matrix in fact it has a
nice physical interpretation the heat on
a vertex at time T given the initial
heat on the other vertex J at time zero
so each entry is like that so it's a
similarity matrix so now you could just
start to cluster the nodes but of course
you can't quite do this because this
matrix is not symmetric and everyone
knows that some similarity matrices have
to be symmetric reviewers told us this
many times so we Scimitar eyes it and
then now we have a symmetric similarity
matrix and then we can cluster choose
your favorite clustering algorithm we
weren't so smart so we just did the
obvious thing you just sort of interpret
these as weights of a graph if you will
complete way to graph this is the
influence graph that Fabio mentioned
threshold and then find connected
components and the resulting threshold
of thing simplest clustering algorithm
ever ok that's hot now that's that's
really what's going on some ways we
didn't even really think we didn't think
about it this way well me when we first
did it we thought about it at slightly
different way which was also bright but
and then this is where we sort of get
into trouble because this immature
ization the way we did it allowed for
these types of artifacts so what's the
solution well the solution we came up
with is maybe we shouldn't Scimitar eyes
this thing let's uh let's keep an
asymmetric there's we're going to fight
with some reviewers and you know let's
try to cluster in a symmetric matrices
which is actually fairly underdeveloped
field there's some work there and again
since we weren't you know wanting to
develop a new clustering algorithm we
just now interpret this as the weights
of a now directed graph complete
directed graph and we threshold and then
now because the graphs directed we
compute strongly connected components ok
so this is the new algorithm which which
we called hot net two or the Spanish
translation hot net dose for diffusing
orient
sub-networks conveying the idea that
we're keeping track of the source of the
heat okay sort of what's really going on
with this asymmetry so there it is why
we got through that mathematical
interlude pretty fast and then the last
step of the algorithm so we do all this
and this is the same for one and two we
do the diffusion we do this extract and
then we have to do this statistical test
okay we've already sort of had some
conversations about statistical tests
that will probably have more one point I
wanted to make about this two-disc full
test is that here the statistical test
is fairly tricky because we're trying to
identify these sub networks in a
priority there's many sub networks that
we're examining when we're doing the
algorithm there's lots you know this is
a big huge multiple hypotheses
correction problem we would have to do
and we need some way to kind of develop
a test where we can get reasonable fdr's
so the solution was to you know look at
the output of the algorithm then when
the statistic we will use is the number
of sub networks of a given minimum size
x sub s now the number of possible
hypotheses X sub s is bounded by the
number of genes the network so there
aren't is there aren't so many this now
we can do a multiple hypotheses
correction on this statistic in doing so
have or we lose one thing and I'm not
going to get into the whole FDR
correction I just want to say that by
doing the statistic here what we're able
to do is produce a list of sub networks
with a false discovery rate on that list
so we would say here's a list of 10 sub
networks output by the algorithm with
the FDR of that list being point one
suggesting that conservatively one of
those ten is wrong a false discovery but
we can't tell you which one you have to
lose something because it's a there's
too many hypotheses and that's sort of
where the loss happens ok so now back to
the details in the last five minutes
here we'll make it on time for lunch
almost if you don't have any questions
so we benchmark pinch markings hard
right i mean i can show you great
simulations where we can just do better
than anything ever produced that's not
very informative so you want to try to
make it as realistic as you can and so
here we try to benchmark on the problem
we're interested in which is finding new
cancer genes but we don't know all the
cans
jeans so we end up making a list of
cancer genes using what's called the the
2020 rule of vogelstein which is that
they you know have I they're clustered
mutations or they have mostly
inactivating mutations and if you create
a list like this and then you look at
how hot net too is doing compared to
hodda compared to pathway based methods
yeah we do pretty well I mean we're sort
of dominating performance and you know
it's it's going in the right direction
so that's good we have other stuff too i
could show you but let me show you the
results then i'll answer all the
questions about all the things we did
all the choices we made here so here's
the pan-cancer analysis that we ended up
with we end up running on three
different interaction networks we found
this with valuable because no single
interaction network was really fully
representative of the biology we thought
we could run the algorithm on separate
ones and then form a consensus of the
results rather than trying to build the
ultimate human interaction network which
is itself a hard problem the end result
is that we find these 16 consensus sub
networks and then these linkers between
them here's the pretty picture that
ended up unfortunately not in nature so
I was wrong but didn't up here and this
nice circle diagram showing you each of
the sub networks so you can't really
read any of this but they're sort of
arranged in the circle according to the
cancer types their enriched they contain
frequently mutated genes well known
cancer genes so that's good but also
rarely mutated ones so I could sort of
zoom in on one here's p53 signaling
again p53 was that super hot node which
caused a bunch of problems before but
now we've got a little bit on more under
control it's still a big network but
many of the genes that we pull in our
real cancer genes as well as some rarely
mutated genes like this see HD eight
which is a chromatin remodelling gene
and turns out more with more recent work
seems to be a real cancer gene but I
won't go into that now we get some other
stuff that was more recently
characterized if we've done the analysis
five years ago we'd be famous because we
discover a whole new bunch of new
protein complexes involved in cancer but
they've all been recently discovered in
the past five years so we're not so
famous and and more stuff like this and
I'll just show you one or two of these
to give you the picture so here's the
cohesin complex and what you can see
this is the genes sry genes across
samples then this color coded thing
which is kind of washed out what you're
seeing is how it's mutated very rarely
across all different cancer types and in
different
opponents of the complex so the
algorithm is actually picking up on the
signal and discovering cohesion because
of both its interactions and its
mutation frequency as a couple years ago
cohesion not widely regarded for its
role in cancer more recently appreciated
as frequently mutated in cancer here
about seven percent of samples digging
further down here's a sister complex of
cohesion called condensin named for its
role and sister chromatin condensation
actually was mentioned in the regulatory
genomics workshop earlier for its role
in chromatin structure and we're finding
again very rare mutations and condensing
that together add up and see then we see
condensing mutated about four percent of
the samples so you go further with this
and we've been doing work where because
we have strongly connected components we
can compute a hierarchy of connected
components this is sort of interesting
because we can kind of dig into the
relative contributions of different
genes to different complexes in terms of
their mutations in cancer and get
relationships between the complexes so
for example we see you know serve well
well known and related complexes kind of
merging in together in the network this
is driven not just by their topology in
the network but also by their mutation
frequencies and then things that are a
little further further afield core
binding proteins etc even within a
complex we can kind of see a bunch of
the well-known cancer genes and notch
signaling sort of merging in together
first some of the stuff that's a little
more speculative and perhaps wrong kind
of merging in later so it gives us a way
to kind of look at the the results and
we're trying to kind of put together
this hierarchical approach into a better
statistical test we're also looking at
bigger data sets now the ICGC has 2,800
whole whole genomes so the number of
samples isn't bigger but we're now
analyzing the whole genome and
non-coding mutations and this this
allows us to do different things and
this time we hope the algorithm will
just run and will write the paper we'll
see yeah we'll see and so here's the
summary of the hot net to stuff it pulls
out sub networks from both topology and
the vertex scores the pathways and
complexes you get out our frequently
contain super currently mutated genes
but also rarely mutated genes and it's
important that you have both the vertex
score and the topology analyzed
simultaneously because if you were to
threshold the score and then look
we at apology you'd probably miss a lot
of the rare stuff and the algorithms
sort of general and just maybe one
minute because actually I'm on Tortola
in one minute I'll just say you know
going further in this direction you've
already kind of heard about this we you
know after doing hot net we we said
that's great problem solved let's go do
something else and so we said let's get
rid of the network and go try to find
combinations of mutations with no prior
information you can't do that so you
need to do something and that something
is you look for these correlations
between mutations or in fact you look at
anti correlation because it had been
observed that mutations within a pathway
you rarely have more than one mutation
in a pathway in an individual patient
you could explain this through a sort of
evolutionary argument that a second
nutation in the pathway doesn't give the
cells a much of a selective advantage
you can explain this observation using
just a counting argument which is that
there are relatively few driver
mutations distributed over multiple
different biological processes so if you
just run the numbers you get
approximately one mutation per pathway
per patient so you sort of see this
phenomenon of in this pathway this is
old beta that there's samples have
rarely have more than one mutation in in
a member of this pathway so turn this
idea around just take your mutation data
and then just go try to find these
signals of sets of mutations or mutated
genes that are mutually exclusive or
approximately exclusive and we sort of
introduced this idea with the dentrix
algorithm and have since iterated on it
multi dentrix along with roediger own
comet the most recent version and Max
slicers and gave a talk on this at the
cancer workshop in February so you can
go view the recorded stream of that and
see that work just one example of this
just analyzing say p53 signaling data
and glioblastoma from about 200 samples
here's one of the sets you kind of pull
out of three genes mutated with copy
number aberrations or mutations sort of
fairly exclusive and in fact it's three
interactions from the p53 signaling
pathway so you're discovering the
interacting genes solely from these anti
correlations or mutual exclusivity
between the mutations so no prior
information discovering the pathways and
we're pushing further on that and with
that I'll end and just acknowledge the
folks that did it of course
amandine who's been mentioned a few
times already Mac slice Orson several
other members of my group some of the
early work collaborations with Ellie
fall at brown and then allowed to pen
cancer analysis collaborations with
several multiple people at other other
institutions and the funding and the
software is all sort of available on the
web page so with that will end happy to
take questions we can go to ah that's a
great question we them the most
frequently mutated stuff we tend to find
with both methods if you really want to
get into kind of these rare mutations
you you you you need the network so the
mutual exclusivity is kind of not really
powerful enough to really get into the
rare mutations and dig into these things
you need to have essentially you need to
have each of these you know in order to
get a statistical signal here kind of
each of these these categories has to be
populated enough so if I have only five
or six samples with the mutation the
mutual exclusivity methods really won't
be able to find that the network method
though Mike and sometimes does but when
you look at the really common stuff that
you tend to get it from both approaches
yeah multiple causes of mutation like
you're a physical entity versus others
yes yes have you ever thought splitting
the mouse to discover yeah yeah it's a
great question we have done that and
that's actually one of the advantages of
doing this type of approach because when
you do the network approach often the
networks are at the gene level and so
you have to collapse all the mutation
level at the gene level or try to piece
out which part of it is somehow
responsible for the interaction which is
harder we've done it here we actually in
fact I've are we already already showed
you that we pulled apart deletion
separately from single nucleotide
variants that's what this D here
indicated we treated them as separate
events in this matrix the amplifications
of mdm2 treated separately from the
snv's we've done it with hot spots and
for ya be Ravi
600 e for example or K rass 12 it's so
frequently mutated that yes we pull that
one out very easily what happens is that
without enough samples you tend to again
get these really rare events and so we
haven't been able to kind of go further
and prioritize things what we've tried
to find and we've only have one example
of this are cases where you might have
two classes of mutations in different
parts of the protein so pik3ca is the
only example where you've got to
essentially two different mutational
classes that can exhibit mutual
exclusivity with different other genes
but we haven't found any other examples
of this we hope it's a power problem
another it seems like you're not really
continuation to go for the whole genome
and talking it to but what is the
relationship between non-coding variants
and the protein that yes there's that
there's the thousand-dollar question so
in the first pass what we're planning to
do is use methods that will take the
non-coding mutations and link them to a
gene right so we try to match the
promoters or enhancers no I mean using
them encode data using known chip seek
Peaks trying to match which enhancers
are affecting which which proteins this
this project is yeah so this this um
it's a big project this ICGC are doing
what's called a peacock project so
there's dozens of groups and multiple of
the groups are exactly trying to you
know interpret the non-coding genome in
various ways and a lot of that has to do
with trying to find which non-coding
elements they can sort of attach
different genes but we're hoping in the
first pass to try to just interviews
those annotations but I don't have
anything to tell you that that's going
to work yet
I workio for some networks what's there
measured ah right yeah so that that
comes down to the this threshold assimil
arity matrix which we is a complete way
to graph and then we just thresholded it
and found strongly connected components
the point is you don't have to Thresh
you could just compute the strongly
connected components overall choices of
threshold and in fact you can do this
even efficiently this is a there's a
version of taärgons algorithm that
actually did a hierarchy of strongly
connected components so that's that's
what's happening is the same similarity
matrix it's just your variant that
similarity matrix came from the heat
times the mutation at scores but you're
finding some networks is really long
more separated as you go along so I mean
the process the process is I'm the
process is just linear algebra right you
just compute that similarity matrix and
then you need to cluster that similarity
matrix and all this is is essentially
just a hierarchical clustering of that
similarity matrix but we're in disposal
to find this to some networks
I'm you know along along the whole way
right so that what we're what sort of
being shown here and this is actually
sort of real real data is like these are
the individual genes you know this this
is the similarity at which they would
merge together in a strongly connected
component so this is this parameter
Delta is this essentially the similarity
as you go across and similarity when are
these journeys genes merging together
into a strongly connected component
could be pretty large and in fact you
know i'm showing you kind of the the you
know we're zooming in on this and i'm
showing you this version a stylized form
because if you actually look at the
whole hierarchy there's a lot of other
stuff going on here so i'm not showing
you every single gene or every single
pathway yeah it is large and it gets
messy make this hard structure on do you
care to rise each so different mission
orders of someday
every time you make this hierarchy to
all members uh well there's only one
there's only one hierarchy and it's
constructed from a single similarity
matrix so I mean think of just gene
expression data and doing hierarchical
clustering right there's a single
similarity matrix between genes and then
i can just hierarchically cluster that
here I guess it's sort of a you know a
glamour of clustering just by kind of
varying this threshold of when I group
things together that's all that's all
that's going on here really it's just
done with strongly connected components
but you know it's essentially threshold
er so think of another way let me take a
you know this this complete weighted
graph that's our similarity matrix right
there's only one hierarchy it says you
vary the threshold the components will
start to merge together so i take this
complete weighted graph if i use the
threshold of cutting as the highest
entry in that matrix then every node is
on its own because there's no edge of
that as i start to lower that threshold
so now i say give me all edges with you
know similarity above a thousand
whatever then i'll get you know a few
edges there and they'll form components
now give me everything with 999 998 997
more edges will start forming in this
graph forming more strongly connected
components and as you vary that
threshold they'll just keep growing and
growing and growing eventually
everything we're just together and you
get the whole graph actually to see so
if you
no way the thing is you you do it wrong
you do it wrong the first time and then
you go fix your problem then you get a
new time yeah yeah we didn't do it wrong
it was fine it was good i don't want to
so the thing is how would that solve the
problem of like the pp threes and all
that right why did you solve those
proper-- yeah I mean it's so you know
it's it's it's somewhat subtle and it's
it's maybe kind of even hard to well I
don't go all the way back in mathematics
but um you know the the idea is somehow
all and how you did this this kind of
scimitar izing property and yeah well
well I mean what you what you really
have is and maybe I should go back if I
came quickly I mean what you really have
is you know this matrix is not symmetric
meaning if i look at you know p53 in one
of its neighbors how similar are they so
I've got one entry telling me p53 and
this neighboring ginia are highly
similar the other entry might be telling
me that they're not very similar and
what happened is they ended up we kind
of ended up always picking the highly
similar version because it was we were
picking the one that was dominated by
the highly mutated gene so p53 was
highly similar to all its neighbors
because of p53 s heat which is on the
one hand true kind of you know PP
there's really hot it has many neighbors
but but the neighbors aren't hot yeah
like so that's where this kind of idea
of we have to look at the neighbor and
see does it have any heat and is it
sending its heat to p53 and that's kind
of what the other entry of the matrix is
doing is sort of telling you how much of
you know the heat on this other gene is
going to p53 granted it's a rarely
mutated gene so it doesn't have a lot of
heat but if it's sending all the p53
then we won't take account of that
said networks that you're finding are
they typically a pan-cancer sub networks
that occur across different tissue types
or are they more likely to be specific
to particular tissues eight cancers it
varies and that's what the fancy circle
diagram was supposed to illustrate
because you know they're arranged
according to their enrichment so we took
every single subnetwork after we got it
and we just did is it enriched in cancer
type with just hyper geometric tests and
then we did this sort of thing so
there's these all these colors you can't
read but like keep one NF e e tu le tu
for example is mostly mutated in
colorectal and lung ad know so it ends
up down here whereas p53 signaling is
curve and mutated in many cancer types
and peak three CA is a little bit in
breast and endometrial they end up over
here specifically possibly explained by
mutations in particular tissue types or
again it depends yeah this is this was
all pan-cancer and I guess to answer an
earlier question we didn't wait this at
all in fact so there's you know it's not
somehow weighted by the number of
mutations per sample I think this was
your earlier question that I didn't
answer sorry the number of samples of
each cancer type so there's a lot more
breast cancer here than there was a
bladder cancer for example we didn't
actually reweighed for that so it's
there's many things you can do in the
analysis but this is just throwing
everything together and sorry your
question was about the mutual
exclusivity yeah that's a whole other
that's that's a whole other talk and you
can watch Max's talk from februari or I
could tell you later about yes you get
mutual exclusivity due to cancer type
and you have to sort of account for that
here for the network analysis we're not
there's no mutual exclusivity we're not
asking for it we don't care if it's
there we're not looking for it whatever
right if you started out with individual
cancer day
mostly it's more samples so you can pose
yeah you know yeah yes you would not get
a lot of the rare stuff so it's very
hard to find these cohesin condensing
things if you do one cancer type at a
time because if you look at the top
cohesion is mutated in total and five
percent of these samples but if you look
at those colors you know each one's a
different cancer type is really rare in
each cancer type so if I just did one
color if I made one cancer type there
it'd be really hard to see the signal
all right